[Música]
hola muy buena noche para todos
bienvenidos a este especial de noticias
en france 24 donde hoy vamos a analizar
el complejo y delicado panorama político
y social que vive colombia debido a las
marchas en contra del gobierno del
presidente iván duque hoy 5 de mayo se
cumplen 8 días de protestas en contra
del gobierno de duquet
los manifestantes se cuentan con una
larga lista de demandas luego de que la
violencia empeorará durante la noche en
la capital bogotá donde 25 estaciones de
policías fueron atacadas a una de ellas
le prendieron fuego mientras los
oficiales permanecían adentro las
protestas originalmente fueron
convocadas en oposición al plan de la
reforma fiscal ya retirada sin embargo
las movilizaciones continúan de manera
mayoritariamente pacíficas y los
ciudadanos exigen retirar un polémico
proyecto de reforma a la salud y exigen
también el fin de la violencia policial
en horas de la tarde se concentraron y
se conocieron denuncias de congresistas
que afirmaron que manifestantes
intentaron ingresar al congreso de la
república y hubo choques con
las manifestaciones han dejado al menos
24 víctimas mortales según la defensoría
del pueblo colombiana y 37 de acuerdo
con ongs locales
estamos en vivo con nuestros periodistas
desde cali luís muñoz y también desde la
ciudad de bogotá a la capital del país
marina sardiña y quiero empezar con
nuestra periodista marina sardina marina
muy buena noche usted se encuentra en
una de estas movilizaciones y
manifestaciones en la ciudad de bogotá
le pregunto el balance de la jornada
hasta ahora cómo ha transcurrido las
manifestaciones
buenas noches raúl las manifestaciones
durante el día de hoy han sido muy
tranquilas han comenzado a primera hora
de la mañana en uno de los puntos más
céntricos de la ciudad del parque
nacional y ha transcurrido de forma
tranquila pacífica habían miles de
personas en las calles que estaban
coreando cánticos arengas había
batucadas había eventos artísticos
porque hoy el día ha sido tranquilo y
pacífico si bien se han dado algunos
hechos de violencia en el centro en la
plaza bolívar en el resto de la ciudad
como hemos podido comprobar durante todo
el día que hemos estado acompañando a
los manifestantes ha sido tranquilo
ahora mismo estamos aquí en el norte de
la ciudad en el monumento de los héroes
donde ha llegan los estudiantes y están
coreando cánticos y siguen resistiendo a
pesar de la lluvia que está cayendo los
manifestantes continúan aquí en una
jornada relativamente tranquila como
digo ahora marina le quiero preguntar
algo curioso y usted que ha cubierto
todas estas manifestaciones en la ciudad
de bogotá me lo puede contestar y es que
cuál es el sentir de la gente que la
gente sigue protestando a pesar de esta
retirada de la reforma tributaria que
fue como la gota que derramó el vaso
para todos
este estallido social de nuevo en
colombia porque sigue protestando la
gente cuáles son las nuevas exigencias
de verdad raúl esto fue una gota que
colmó el vaso como dices porque las
protestas vienen sucediéndose desde el
pasado 2019 y ahí es durante la pandemia
ha habido un incremento de la pobreza
del 42 5%
de los ciudadanos colombianos están en
situación de pobreza esto es uno de los
motivos por los cuales los manifestantes
se están manifestando hoy aquí pero
también por el clima de violencia que se
ha vivido durante las protestas la
represión como vienen condenando
organismos internacionales y también
organismos colombianos es ha sido muy
fuerte contra los manifestantes en su
mayoría pacíficos y ha habido ciertos
enfrentamientos con ellos pero la
violencia policial acción muy fuerte y
este es uno de los lemas que se está
repitiendo hoy aquí en las calles y es
que cese la violencia que cese la
represión contra los manifestantes que
están exigiendo derechos que están
restringiendo mejores salariales que
están exigiendo retirar la reforma a la
salud y también por debido a la
situación de la pandemia como digo ha
agravado mucho la situación económica en
el país y por ello los manifestantes
continúan aquí y él y el lema principal
como digo es el cese de la violencia
contra los manifestantes pacíficos en su
mayoría jóvenes así es bart en usted
también hablo de dos puntos importantes
no hay que olvidar que colombia está
pasando por el tercer pico de la
pandemia de kobe 19 con un elevado
número de fallecidos diarios y también
de contagios diarios además con estas
manifestaciones pues posiblemente por
las aglomeraciones se pueden dar mayor
número de contagios marinas ya la ciudad
de bogotá por ejemplo está con más del
95% de ocupación de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos y también usted
marina hablaba de las condenas
internacionales le quiero preguntar
luego de este rechazo internacional de
organismos internacionales valga la
redundancia le quiero preguntar cómo se
ha comportado la policía en la capital
colombiana y también si la gente tiene
miedo de este tercer pico de la pandemia
bueno pues durante el día apenas hemos
visto presencia policial en las marchas
acompañándolos a los manifestantes no
hemos visto en si presencia policial si
es cierto que en el centro de la ciudad
como digo hubo un pequeño altercado
algún pequeño grupo de manifestantes
intentaron asaltar el congreso y la
policía antidisturbios los dispersó con
gases lagrimógenos a partir de aquí lo
que sucedió es que sí que se han llevado
a cabo una represión bastante fuerte en
el centro de la ciudad donde como digo
se han estado lanzando gases
lacrimógenos estaban las tanquetas pero
eso ha sido en el centro en el resto de
la ciudad ha habido una calma tranquila
unas marchas pacíficas con cánticos no
ha habido apenas presencia policial y
eso pues es destacable porque durante
estos días sí hemos visto mucha
presencia policial y en cuanto al
coronavirus realmente este fin de semana
la alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez ha
levantado las restricciones que vienen
impuestas desde hace más de tres semanas
del pico y cédula que es para entrar a
los comercios y también ha dicho que va
a reabrir los restaurantes y otros
y tiendas y supermercados no sabemos muy
bien si esto es en respuesta al paro
nacional o es una petición que viene
siendo de los comerciantes colombianos
debido a que la crisis económica se está
agravando muy fuertemente debido a la
pandemia así es marina gracias por la
información desde la ciudad de bogotá en
un momento vuelvo con usted para una
actualización de lo que ocurre en las
calles de la capital colombiana por lo
pronto me voy hasta la ciudad de cali
santiago de cali con nuestro enviado
especial
luís muñoz lluís muy buena noche donde
ha estado el día de hoy y también le
pregunto que ha visto en la ciudad cómo
están los ánimos
buenas noches raúl mira si hoy hemos
estado en un barrio conocido como puerto
rellena que ahora estado rebautizado
como puerto resistencia allí hemos
podido entrar y hemos encontrado que los
manifestantes tienen como una especie de
glorieta controlada donde no puede
acceder la policía la verdad es que
tienen una gran organización se
comunican autorizan el paso y dentro
pues hemos podido ver que hay un sitio
donde no hay control del estado pero sin
embargo hay la estación de policía ahora
es una biblioteca donde ellos se
gestionan las bebidas donde ellos se
gestionan las comidas donde hay
actuaciones artísticas donde también hay
presencia de la minga que está apoyando
a estos jóvenes y hemos podido conversar
con ellos y también con otros vecinos y
lo que nos hemos encontrado es algo
sorprendente y es que los vecinos apoyan
a estos manifestantes son jóvenes que
nos han contado que están cansados de la
pobreza en una ciudad como cali que
tiene cerca de un millón de habitantes
en pobreza extrema unos datos que la
verdad que son alarmantes y ellos nos
decían todo el rato que no son vándalos
y que también nos decían que piensan
resistir y que la policía les está
atacando
para usted que ha estado también unos
cuantos días en la ciudad de cali le
pregunto cómo están las calles del mundo
también ha conocido pues todo lo que ha
ocurrido el vandalismo en algunos sitios
el choque con la policía los
manifestantes pero le pregunta usted que
está en la ciudad de cali cuál es el
ambiente real en las calles
si aquí con el equipo con mi compañero
con el cámara juan carlos zapata
conversamos mucho de lo que nos está
costando asimilar realmente lo que
estamos viendo las calles de cali por
ejemplo y durante el día no hemos visto
presencia policial policial ni militar
sin embargo ahora que ha llegado la
noche frente al hotel han pasado como 20
motos con un policía y con una gente del
esmad la unidad antidisturbios entonces
nos cuesta un poco entender no la
dinámica en las calles desiertas durante
el día se ven pocos coches se ve poca
gente por la calle excepto en los puntos
de concentración que se han formado
alrededor de cali que son como puntos
conocen los manifestantes de resistencia
donde son como comunidades autónomas no
para destacar
pues eso que la policía es lo que está
denunciando todos los manifestantes en
los barrios que por favor piden que se
vayan las organizaciones de derechos
humanos por la noche que es cuando
aparece la policía y cuando se están
denunciando esos actos de abuso policial
bien si también le quiero preguntar
sobre el desabastecimiento en la ciudad
de cali tanto de comida como de
combustible que se también también se
habla mucho por las redes sociales hay
muchas denuncias de ciudadanos sobre el
desabastecimiento en la ciudad que hay
sobre esto
es lo que están denunciando gran parte
de vecinos sin embargo nosotros hoy por
ejemplo nos entra un supermercado y sí
que es verdad que estaban todos los
cajones y estanterías vacíos luego hemos
estado también en una tiendita de barrio
y ahí sí que hemos visto que había
abastecimiento en cuanto a la gasolina
por ejemplo nuestro conductor hoy ha
estado horas desde las 5 de la mañana
hasta cerca del mediodía para poder
repostar sin embargo también hemos visto
como en otra estación había
manifestantes que habían tomar la
manifestación y se estaban sirviendo
gasolina entonces todo en cali ahora
mismo es muy incierto en todos los
aspectos también cabe destacar que han
conseguido por sameco uno de los puntos
más calientes de la ciudad de cali habrá
abrir un corredor humanitario por el que
estarían entrando alimentos no es
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información vuelvo con usted más
adelante para seguir hablando de esta
situación que hay en el departamento del
valle del cauca nos ciudad de khar en el
sur exigen en el sur occidente del país
de colombia quiero saludar ahora a
nuestro primer invitado víctor de correa
lugo profesor universitario analista
internacional víctor muy buena noche un
gusto saludarlo nuevamente le pregunto
en su opinión el balance
de estas protestas tanto político como
social
la primera es que se tumbó una reforma
tributaria que no recogía el sentir de
la población colombiana ni personas
doctas en economía ni las personas de a
pie que hacen mercado en la esquina se
sentían reflejadas se sentían respetadas
con una reforma tributaria tercera bajo
el gobierno de duke que buscaba ahondar
la brecha entre los más ricos y los más
pobres colombia son los países con mayor
inequidad en el mundo y la reforma
tributaria no buscaba más que ahondar en
ese modelo por eso más allá de
discusiones tecnocráticas que les
encanta mencionar a los señores
defensores del gobierno lo que uno
encuentra de fondo es que la gente dijo
nomás no vamos a pagar más impuestos
mientras el gobierno se gasta unas
millonadas de peso queriendo comprar
aviones de guerra o en términos de la
corrupción y en términos sociales yo veo
un gran despertar de la sociedad
especialmente de los jóvenes de sectores
importantes que vemos ahora mismo en en
imagen como el sector salud
de diferentes hoy marcharon por ejemplo
los recicladores los indígenas y son el
reflejo del fiel reflejo de un país que
no se siente reconocido ni en los
partidos políticos ni tampoco en la
institucionalidad entonces lo que se
demuestra aquí primero es que las calles
son capaces de tumbar una reforma
agraria y tributaria de tumbar a un
ministro y de imponer una agenda
política que sea más acorde a la
realidad no se puede seguir gobernando
de espalda al país ahora víctor porque
de presentar el proyecto ahora y porque
ir directamente con un plan tan
ambicioso y agresivo si se quiere para
la clase media colombiana además le
pregunto cuál es la situación la
situación real y actual el fiscal de
colombia
a ver colombia es un país de renta media
donde no es un país pobre el problema no
tiene que ver con la disponibilidad de
recursos tiene que ver con esos recursos
para dónde van y cómo se manejan y con
qué criterios se manejan por ejemplo en
materia de salud nosotros tenemos muchos
recursos en salud pero esos recursos se
los apropia el intermediario
financiero llamado en colombia' ips que
es la que regula la relación entre los
hospitales y las los pacientes igual
podríamos mirar con diferentes sectores
cuando uno piensa como un gobierno
reparte el presupuesto pues vemos que
hay un gran presupuesto para la lucha
armada para las fuerzas armadas pero hay
un bajo presupuesto en términos por
ejemplo de educación solo para dar un
dato la semana pasada según cifras
oficiales demuestran que el 42 por
ciento
de la población colombiana 21 millones
de personas están por debajo de la línea
de pobreza 3 una no puede nosotros no
entendemos como frente a un drama tan
grande se cae en el error de querer
cobrarle a la gente de seguirle sacando
los recursos a la gente es más de si
revisamos cómo se supone se supera la
crisis de la gran depresión del 29 y el
plan marchas de la segunda guerra
mundial pues lo que encontramos es que
el estado juega un papel de inversor
para reactivar la economía aquí han
presentado siete proyectos indicando de
dónde se puede sacar plata para la renta
básica para que la gente pueda comer
comprar reactivar la economía sin
embargo el gobierno no hace caso a ello
si había destinado una ingente cantidad
de dinero para la aerolínea avianca que
ni siquiera es una aerolínea que esté
que sea colombiana ha habido una
cantidad de recursos para comprar
equipos de vigilancia y modernizar
sistemas de escoltas en el país en medio
de la crisis no ha habido una gestión
adecuada
de la pandemia entonces la crisis
estructural de injusticia y de inequidad
más la crisis de pobreza de los últimos
años que hizo aguas en el año 2019 más
el manejo de la pandemia que a todas
luces y con datos estadísticos y números
claros demuestran la gran equivocación
de la política frente a la pandemia se
asuman esos tres criterios para explicar
por qué se vuelca a la ciudadanía a
partir del 28 de abril a las calles y
porque además víctor le preguntó el
presidente de duke y su gobierno
intentaron poner esta reforma tributaria
en medio de este tercer pico de la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 donde la gente
está cansada del encierro cansada de no
poder trabajar pues evidentemente los
recursos han mermado en la sociedad
colombiana calcularon bien el costo
político
yo creo que no ellos me parece que el
problema de los gobiernos autoritarios
que gobiernan dándole la espalda al país
es que no miden la responsabilidad que
tienen en materia de incendiar el país
que está incendiando el país no son los
jóvenes algunos de ellos muertos en las
calles colombianas no son las políticas
sociales que la gente ya no aguanta es
decir no es posible que en colombia se
le quieran poner impuestos agregados a
los huevos al café colombia un país que
produce el café el café colombiano tan
famoso bueno pues ahora con un impuesto
a una cantidad de cosas decir que el
azúcar no es un producto esencial decir
a la gente que se toma un café con
azúcar para ir a comenzar el trabajo ya
recibiría un impuesto del 19 por ciento
es absolutamente injusto es colocarle
impuestos a las honras fúnebres o sea a
la gente si allá no tenemos derecho ni a
morirnos eso es una realidad es decir
ahí están los números los estudios
estadísticos las propuestas para creer
que no es sobra ni de un complot
internacional ni de una una red de
organizaciones del narcoterrorismo como
está diciendo el gobierno nuestro es un
paro que se llaman donde la gente está
saliendo en los barrios las imágenes que
ustedes están mostrando en este momento
son de gente joven de gente con
pancartas con música tratando de decir
oiga escuchemos yo creo que sé qué es
realmente y la palabra es infamia es
infame tratar de representar un clamor
constitucional el derecho de la gente la
protesta reducirlo a un problema de
vandalismo
luego de ese de vandalismo saltamos a un
discurso de que no es vandalismo sino
terrorismo y a partir de ahí justificar
unas cosas terribles que precisamente
instituciones como el congreso de los
eeuu ha salido a condenar que la unión
europea ha sabido ha salido a condenar
entonces no es una alcahuetería ni una
en falta de tacto ni un problema de
terrorismo y vandalismo es una protesta
social que la comunidad internacional
está discutiendo y lo que muestra el
fracaso del gobierno en su gestión
política económica y social victoria nos
vamos a meter en esas aguas de lo que
dice el gobierno que detrás de estas
protestas sociales entonces están grupos
al margen de la ley como por ejemplo él
ln y algunas disidencias de las farc y
terrorismo doméstico pero hablemos de
algo que también está en la mesa ya esta
reforma tributaria
el presidente de duke dijo un paso atrás
por todo lo que estaba ocurriendo en el
país pero permanece todavía en la
ciudadanía el descontento social
ahora se protesta contra una posible
reforma a sistemas
que hay con esta posible reforma al
sistema de salud en colombia
pero el sistema de salud en colombia
está creado el nuevo sistema a partir
del año 1993 cuyo senador ponente de esa
ley fue precisamente álvaro uribe vélez
y copia el modelo de intermediación que
se hizo en chile que hizo el dictador
pinochet es un modelo donde yo ya no voy
a un hospital no me relaciono
directamente con un servicio de salud
sino que todo pasa por un intermediario
que se llama dps es a efe ese es la que
regula la relación entre el paciente la
persona y el hospital y que hace para
ganar ofrecen lo menos posible al
paciente y paga lo menos posible el
hospital ese modelo no estoy diciendo
una manera muy simple tiene otras
complejidades con el nuevo proyecto de
ley no va a reformar la salud para
resolver los problemas que ya ha
evidenciado sin modelo duramente durante
27 años además con males que los hemos
visto en la atención de la pandemia
entonces los médicos tienen un salario
terrible los enfermeros las
el personal de salud en general y vemos
entonces ese mal pago esa explotación
laboral por culpa de una política y es
buscar la ganancia cuando la salud se
vuelve una mercancía pues no hay nada
que hacer el proyecto de ley que hay
cursa el que es el famoso proyecto 010
no modifica eso sino que lo perpetúa lo
ahonda y privatiza aún más el modelo
cercano un modelo es como el que se vive
en los eeuu the age
entonces en ese sentido el sector salud
lo que ha dicho es hombre en vez de
avanzar hacia la equidad damos un paso
hacia atrás
por eso el economista del sector salud
el personal de salud el personal que
está sufriendo el día a día la atención
de la pandemia rechaza está esta
pandemia que está propuesta también
porque nos parece triste es lamentable
que la presente precisamente en la mitad
de una pandemia entonces parece que la
pandemia ha servido de excusa para la
reforma tributaria pero además de eso
hay una reforma en salud hay una reforma
laboral en curso de una reforma de
pensiones en curso y hay un gobierno
autoritario entonces si sumamos un
gobierno autoritario que no de espacios
políticos un gobierno que no mira la
realidad un gobierno que no maneja la
pandemia y una serie de políticas
socioeconómicas que hacen agua pues la
gente hay que escucharla víctor lo
invito a usted ya los televidentes que
damos la siguiente nota donde resumimos
lo que ocurrió ayer la jornada violenta
que vivimos en la ciudad de bogotá vamos
a ver
colombia vivió una nueva jornada de
tensión tras una semana de protestas en
las calles eeuu la unión europea y la
onu rechazaron el uso excesivo de la
fuerza al margen de las manifestaciones
que nacieron en rechazo al proyecto de
reforma tributaria de iván duque y que
tras su retiro derivaron en un reclamo
por igualdad social y en rechazo a la
violencia policial las organizaciones
sociales que desde el pasado miércoles
movilizan a miles de personas en todo el
país salieron a las calles para exigir
garantías constitucionales a la protesta
la desmilitarización de las ciudades y
una negociación con el gobierno sobre el
sistema de salud y la renta básica entre
otros puntos ante el escalamiento de las
tensiones el presidente colombiana
anunció la instalación de una mesa de
diálogo nacional para encontrar una
salida pacífica que instalaremos un
espacio para escuchar a la ciudadanía y
construir soluciones orientado a estos
propósitos en los cuales no deben mediar
diferencias ideológicas sino nuestro más
profundo patriotismo
en este espacio es vital contar con
todas las instituciones los partidos el
sector privado gobernadores alcaldes y
líderes de la sociedad civil motivadas
por el servicio a la ciudadanía los
casos de brutalidad policial divulgados
a través de redes sociales despertaron
la alerta para la comunidad
internacional dada la situación
extremadamente tensa con soldados y
policías desplegados para vigilar la
protesta pedimos calma recordamos a las
autoridades estatales su responsabilidad
de proteger los derechos humanos
incluido el derecho a la vida y la
seguridad de la persona y de facilitar
el ejercicio del derecho a la libertad
de reunión pacífica artistas y
deportistas colombianos también han
condenado el uso desproporcionado de la
fuerza para controlar la protesta social
las páginas web del ejército del senado
y la presidencia de colombia fueron
pirateadas además el grupo de hackers
anonymous publicó una lista de correos y
contraseñas de miembros del ejército
continuamos analizando lo que ocurre en
colombia debido a este estallido social
que empezó en rechazo a la reforma
tributaria que presentó el gobierno del
presidente iván duque pero ya que ya fue
retirada del congreso estábamos
conversando con víctor de currea víctor
vuelvo con usted ya estamos entrando en
un círculo vicioso tú me agrede yo te
agrego como fuerza porque optar por una
represión tan violenta como lo que como
la que ha sido denunciado por la
ciudadanía y como la que hemos visto en
las redes sociales
me parece que tiene que ver con una
concepción autoritaria del poder que eso
es una cosa muy típica del uribismo
recordemos que el presidente duque es la
figura que es propuesta como candidato
más exactamente impuesta como candidato
por el señor expresidente uribe entonces
a partir de allí se consolida un tipo de
gobierno es un gobierno autoritario es
un gobierno es una forma de entender la
política donde mediana fuerza donde no
medie el diálogo y el problema es que se
empujan las comunidades a una acción
similar decir los indígenas colombianos
protestan pacíficamente más van cartas
nadie les parábolas bloquean la
carretera a veces y les ponen cuidado
cuál es el mensaje que está mandando el
gobierno colombiano
su mensaje triste su mensaje de si usted
respeta la norma pide la reunión es
manda un proyecto pide una solicitud no
es escuchado pero si usted bloquea la
calle es escuchado fíjense cómo es el
estado
que manda un mensaje que es
terriblemente perverso ahora por
supuesto que ha habido actos de
vandalismo pero lo que no se puede es
crear una mitología por ejemplo cuando
sale no voy a decir es que hay grupos
dlna skylark y fusilería de alto calibre
en manos de los protesta de las
protestas hombre si alguien tuviera un
fusil de asalto créame que los fusiles
los helicópteros no volarían tan tan
bajito eso nadie que sepa un poquito yo
he cubierto algunos conflictos armados y
nadie va a ser un error de eso pero
además de eso no hay reportes de
policías heridos de bala y me alegra y
ojalá no los haya pero se crea una
narrativa que invita a los medios de
comunicación a que solamente veamos la
pedrea y no los cientos de miles de
personas que están pidiendo de
adecuadamente respetuosamente una una
unas solicitudes sociales lo otro que me
preocupa mucho es que el debate se
vuelve estético entonces seguro el
problema de cómo se protestan o de por
qué se protesta y entonces las causas de
la protesta
es una pésima política social termina
diluyéndose y lo que hablamos únicamente
son de las consecuencias de la protesta
por supuesto que eso tiene un problema y
es que querer imponer una protesta
entonces que se haga a las 8 de la
mañana por el andén esto no quiere decir
que la única opción sea la violencia
como la que estamos observando ahora
mismo en las imágenes yo no he dicho eso
no he patrocinado ese tipo de actos pero
estoy diciendo hay un afán por construir
un sujeto de político que se reduce
únicamente a ser entonces lo más cercano
a un terrorista urbano
víctor y ya vamos a hablar sobre esa
proporción de represión con las con las
manifestaciones y los actos vandálicos
que decía es verdad que también se han
presentado en varias ciudades en la
ciudad de cali y la ciudad de bogotá
pero le quiero dar la bienvenida a
nuestro otro invitado eduard rodríguez
representante a la cámara del centro
democrático el partido de gobierno del
presidente iván duque gracias por estar
con nosotros
rodríguez aquí en france24 le deseo una
muy buena noche y quiero escuchar su
opinión y su posición sobre lo que está
ocurriendo en el país y el balance que
le da a todas estas protestas que hemos
vivido los últimos los últimos ocho días
pues como tú dices no son tan buenas
noches ha habido o ha existido en
colombia pues una zozobra que tiene que
mirarse observarse con mucha humildad
durante todo tiene que también mirar
como nos escuchamos como como ciudadanos
entendemos que hay que la primero que la
protesta social es un derecho
fundamental consagrado en nuestra
constitución
y que además hay que respetarla pero que
esa protesta social nada tiene que ver
con hechos vandálicos con organizaciones
criminales que infiltran dicha protesta
social que vuelve vivo es respetable yo
mismo he sido el autor de varias marchas
cuando por ejemplo nosotros estábamos en
contra de la impunidad del acuerdo entre
las farc y el gobierno de juan manuel
santos pero y salíamos a la plaza
bolívar pero marchábamos protestábamos
recogíamos inclusive si dejaba alguien
en el papel papeles en la plaza bolívar
limpiamos la plaza bolívar pero esas son
las marchas que incentivan y que hay que
escucharlas porque son parte de lo que
la ciudadanía nos haciendo y su por
supuesto que hay un descontento y lo
importante no es mantener el descontento
sino como traducimos ese descontento en
políticas públicas hay que recordar que
ahorita estamos en el cob y que tenemos
uno de los picos más altos que es parte
de nuestra preocupación
y vuelvo a decir aquí lo importante es
diferenciar las dos cosas la protesta
social y lo otro que es cómo se
enquistan algunas organizaciones
criminales y generan actos vandálicos
que pues son reprimidos por la fuerza
pública bajo un estricto protección de
derechos humanos hay que recordar que
colombia ha avanzado mucho en capacitar
a su fuerza pública en derechos humanos
y pues también entender que así como lo
muestran las imágenes pues hay algunas
organizaciones criminales que aprovechan
dicen que están haciendo protestas pero
lo que están haciendo es atacar a la
fuerza pública hasta el punto de que
tratan de mente de quemar a 11 policías
aquí al sur de bogotá 11 policías que
tienen hijos que tienen esposa que tiene
miedo que no quieren ya ni salir de sus
casas y no entienden porque sé que se
les trata de agredir y porque se les
trata de maltratar ahora bien si hay
persona social ha existido seguramente
actos vandálicos o actos no acordes a la
ley por parte de la policía pues
nosotros somos una democracia y sabrá la
sabrá la justicia castigar a aquellos
que no han cumplido los protocolos de
derechos humanos pero aquí lo que
tenemos es que avanzar por una parte en
el diálogo y rechazar completamente a
los van al vandalismo terrorista que
quiere infiltrar la protesta y quiere
generar miedo y caos en colombia'
representante pero si la policía como
usted bien lo dice tiene miedo de salir
a las calles por todos estos actos en su
contra quien defiende el pueblo
es que ese es un tema muy complejo
porque mire usted yo le estoy hablando
de lo que mis propios las personas que
cuidan de mí porque pues he tenido
varias amenazas por parte de las de ln
de las disidencias trataron de hacerme
un atentado pero pero ellos mismos me
dicen mire nosotros queremos volver a
nuestras casas nosotros no salimos a una
marcha para agredir a alguien pero lo
que uno ve sistemáticamente es que hay
organizaciones criminales que andan
haciendo y trataron de hecho de tomarse
el congreso y andan haciendo desórdenes
y a esas organizaciones criminales yo le
he hecho un llamado a la ciudadanía para
que empecemos nosotros como ciudadanos a
expulsarlos y expulsarlos por una parte
de la marcha pacífica y por otra parte
expulsarlos de nuestro propio entorno a
fin de que esas personas sean
individualizadas capturadas y judicial
izadas y se respete por una parte la
protesta social pero también se respete
a la fuerza pública porque antes de
portar un uniforme son seres humanos y
por eso
nosotros hemos hecho el llamado a
protegerlos
gracias representante ya vuelvo con
usted quiero ir nuevamente con nuestro
invitado víctor de currea víctor y hay
terrorismo urbano infiltrado detrás de
estas protestas como lo dice el partido
de gobierno del presidente iván duque yo
quiero precisar algunas cosas yo no sé
en qué país vive el señor congresista
que nos acompaña pero el año hace poco
diego cancino el concejal de bogotá
denunció como 11 personas jóvenes
murieron calcinados en un centro de
policía que se incendio que fue
incendiado por la policía en soacha y
mucha gente le pregunta a un hombre qué
pasó con esa investigación
aquí hubo 14 muertos entre el 9 y 10 de
septiembre del año pasado y sin embargo
uno pregunta qué pasó con la
investigación hay cualquier cantidad de
casos donde el esmad ha asesinado
jóvenes como el caso de este muchacho
neira en el centro de bogotá y qué pasó
con la investigación de resultados 17
años
entonces me parece que es profundamente
peligroso mentir sobre la labor de la
policía cuando uno ve prácticas que son
sistemáticas y los derechos humanos son
claros la segunda cosa es que no
hablemos de derechos humanos o sea de
los derechos humanos no es que hagan
cursos yo he sido profesor de derechos
humanos en cursos de la policía eso no
se mide por cursos se mide por
resultados este año tenemos 32 masacres
han matado 200 de 32 ex combatientes de
las far desde cuando se firmó el proceso
de paz más de 500 líderes asesinados y
estoy en contra del vandalismo terminó
citando un tuit que acaba de poner
carlos caicedo que es el gobernador de
magdalena quien dice lo siguiente
comillas en barrio de santa marta y
ciénaga bandas de microtráfico y
políticos de extrema derecha uribistas
incitan algunos con droga y dinero a la
destrucción de cádiz y locales
comerciales como periodista cubrir las
marchas del 21 de noviembre del año 2019
y vi y registre como varios de esos
vándalos después terminaban
de la policía protegidos por ellos
entonces a ver si vamos a hablar de
vandalismo es tengo ningún problema
condenó el intento de incendiar a los
policías pero vamos a ser sinceros yo no
creo que sea decente mentirle al país
que no está oyendo sobre todo a un país
que conoce lo que está pasando que está
hasta el copete de ver imágenes de
policías golpeando de manera sistemática
y un comandante de la fuerza militar es
un presidente que sale aplaudirlos y a
decirles lo que están haciendo está bien
si esto fuera un estado de derecho
créame que en un estado de derecho no se
verían balas re calzadas como lo
confesado ante la justicia
policías del esmad con las cuales
produjeron muerte en marchas
estudiantiles o el uso de armas de fuego
dentro de manifestaciones yo creo que el
asesinato de dylan ahora dirá
edward que fue que como decía la
fiscalía se le atravesó yo creo que hay
que ser un poquito respetuoso sobre todo
es que no están o no están interesando
en en uzbekistán es decir cualquier
persona que no está viendo puede salir a
la calle a las redes sociales y ver la
realidad
entonces claro que rechazamos la
manipulación de las protestas sociales
que no estamos de acuerdo estamos de
acuerdo aunque las protestas sociales
son un derecho constitucional por lo que
no podemos decir es que si un gobernador
se legítimamente elegido dice lo que
dice entonces aquí tratemos de decir que
se le eliminan y las farc para des visto
desvirtuar los debates reales que la
gente protesta porque gente como ustedes
la del centro democrático proponen unas
políticas sociales y económicas
absolutamente inequitativas
representante voy con usted y para que
por supuesto ejerza su derecho a la
palabra de lo que quiera decir y también
le quiero preguntar y preguntar cuál
sería la proporción justa para que no
resulten más actos de vandalismo y
enfrentamientos entre los manifestantes
y las fuerzas del orden yo pues yo yo
partiría porque aquí tenemos que
ponernos de acuerdo en lo fundamental y
con todo respeto profesor yo creo que
usted parte de la lógica de que yo soy
mentiroso y creo que yo en ningún
momento he dicho mentiras tengo una
visión
es una visión que puede que ustedes les
suene equivoca pero no parto de de
decirle a usted o de maltratar al
oponente y en eso tenemos que cambiar en
eso tenemos que ponernos de acuerdo como
colombianos entender diferentes visiones
y no solamente la visión que usted
democráticamente representa yo quiero
hacer advertencia de hoy lo que se ha
reportado 581 bloqueos 695 uniformados
lesionados padres madres e hijos que
están de ellos 25 hospitalizados 324
civiles heridos y yo le quiero decir
quién gana absolutamente nada aquí nadie
gana sobre sobre esas lesiones el
asesinato de esos ciudadanos es
completamente condenables como es
completamente condenables que a un
oficial de la policía le propine más de
42 puñaladas
eso no se puede justificar en una
democracia y mire usted usted habla de
un tema de un gobernador de izquierda
el sur del perdón en el norte del país
que es el gobernador del magdalena y
nosotros tenemos todo toda una
información completamente diferente a la
que usted está proporcionándole a la
ciudadanía y es que el propio gobernador
es el que está haciendo lo que usted
dice entonces aquí tenemos que desarmar
la palabra y entender que por un lado
hay unas quejas unas quejas sociales que
hay que mirar cómo solucionamos entre
todos nosotros que estamos proponiendo
educación gratuita para estratos 1 2 y 3
estamos proponiendo llegarle a 5
millones de familias o sea casi 18
millones de colombianos con más o menos
4 millones 800 mil pesos al año eso es
una política para reactivar la economía
para ayudar a la gente que hoy se está
muriendo de hambre que está reclamando
es para eso era de la reforma social y
hablaremos de más temas como es como
tenemos que nosotros sostener unos
programas sociales que nos han ayudado y
que hemos venido trabajando no ayer sino
durante muchos años que redujeron
completamente la pobreza entonces aquí
lo que es lo que se trata es de
por dar ideas de cómo solucionamos una
problemática por supuesto que es mi
partido yo mismo salí preocupado cuando
se presentó esa reforma que le rogamos
al gobierno que no se presentará en
presentada que hubo errores y nosotros
humildemente nos aceptamos y los
criticamos y dijimos no vamos a votar
algunos temas esenciales de esa reforma
pero aquí podemos quedarnos en dos temas
uno en la pelea en la contienda en mirar
cómo se matan unos con otros o empezar a
aportar ideas a través del diálogo y
solucionar problemáticas de forma aquí
hay una muy preocupante me llama
poderosamente la atención de que esté
hablando de políticas contra la pobreza
eran dos opciones
médica van a decir que usted habla de
políticas contra la pobreza que el
centro democrático mejora la lucha
contra la pobreza bueno el dany creo que
usted respeta el dane como fuente de
información no refleja que un aumento de
la pobreza y esta marea el 42-0 cierran
me parece en sus dos lados sobre ahora
le pido que me escuchen segunda cosa de
carlos caicedo yo espero que usted lo
demande o sea como usted me dice que
usted no miente pues vaya a los
tribunales porque hay en lo que yo cité
pues entonces de manera lo que siento es
que su partido es parte de los que han
negociado cientos de acuerdos de
carretera con los indígenas del cauca
decenas con los campesinos de catatumbo
y se los han incumplido de manera
reiterativa me llama la atención que
usted habla de los militares muertos de
los policías heridos que me parece bien
pero no hay ninguna mención de su
partido jamás condenándolo de dylan
jamás hay una mención de los 24 muertos
civiles que se han hecho no hay ninguna
mención de usted sobre los muchachos que
permanecen desaparecidos no por supuesto
ahora ya
el diálogo porque no aceptaron el
diálogo en el 2019 por ejemplo cuando se
les planteó y porque si vamos a hablar
de cosas serias hablemos de cosas serias
hablemos del fracking hablemos del
glifosato hablemos de esas cosas ustedes
no pueden incendiar el país y luego
cuando ven que la sociedad sale a la
calle salir a decir hagámonos pasito me
parece que es un acto de absoluta
irresponsabilidad no se trata de hacer
llamados a la bandera claro señor
me encantaría que nos sentáramos pero no
hoy tiene que sentar sobre cosas reales
usted están llamando a hablar para
resolver un problema social a la
vacunación la vacunación el deber del
gobierno uribista perdón sobre la
violencia ustedes les valía con
implementar el proceso de paz que lo
hicieron trizas sobre la vulnerabilidad
las personas vulnerables de verdad se
meta un paro para que ustedes entiendan
que cumplirle a las personas vulnerables
no es un favor no es fruto de la
negociación es que es el deber
constitucional que tiene el gobierno
entonces me parece que las trampas en
las que están cayendo ustedes son
terribles porque ahora que se sienten
acorralados ahora que la gente está en
la calle ahora que la gente está
poniendo
ustedes no reconocen y no reconocen en
su dignidad ahora que ustedes están
acusando a sacar tropas ahora que uribe
está llamando a la guerra porque eso es
lo que está haciendo entre ustedes
llamar a la concordia ya la paz porque
no lo hicieron en el 2020 porque no lo
hicieron en los 19 pero quiero no puede
hacerles una encerrona a la sociedad y
luego presentarse qué pena qué van a
hacer para ir avanzando en soluciones a
esta crisis política y social que vive
colombia en este momento me quedo con lo
que dijo el representante de aportar
soluciones el tiempo se me acaba
solamente nos quedan aproximadamente 18
minutos de programa y quisiera tocar
estos estos puntos de las soluciones a
esta crisis que afecta tanto a colombia
en este tercer pico de la pandemia de
covite 19 representante cómo queda el
gobierno de iván duque después de todo
esto perder al ministro al ministro de
hacienda retirar esta reforma tributaria
y qué soluciones le pone entonces al
país usted
como representante del partido de
gobierno nosotros hemos planteado dos
elementos uno que es vacunación masiva y
reactivación segura vacunación masiva
hoy tenemos 10 millones de vacunas pero
no 9 millones 600 mil vacunas llamamos
para las 10 hemos avanzado en que los
mayores de 60 años estén vacunados y
hemos avanzado
poco a poco de acuerdo a lo que el
mercado mundial de vacunas permite a
través del sistema cobas estamos
ayudándole a la ciudadanía no obstante
tenemos unos problemas de reactivación
económica muy complejos que necesitamos
hacer crecer al 6% para crecer al 6% hay
que mantener una política social
sostenible hay que generar una política
de emprendimiento y basado en eso
nosotros hemos propuesto varias ideas
entre otras como terminar las obras de
infraestructura para generar digamos qué
empleabilidad cómo reducir la tasa de
desempleo que es muy preocupante
a través de políticas públicas general
que la ciudadanía pueda volver a la
normalidad nosotros veníamos creciendo
al 41 puntos por ciento nosotros
veníamos cumpliendo en una agenda donde
la inseguridad se ha bajado notablemente
y nosotros veníamos trabajando
arduamente por crear un país con equidad
con legalidad y con emprendimiento que
son han sido las banderas que hemos
abordado con el presidente iván duque
que hay que hacer uno el país tiene que
ponerse de acuerdo de dónde va a sacar
sus fuentes de financiación para cumplir
con los programas sociales para cumplir
con los programas de emprendimiento
económico y para cumplir las metas de
legalidad que son parte fundamental de
lo que el gobierno se propuso con lo que
le propuso a los colombianos 2
en eso nosotros queremos y hemos hecho
un llamado a todas las fuerzas políticas
para dialogar sobre estos elementos de
cómo salir adelante cuáles son las
circunstancias cómo le vamos a cumplir a
los más pobres sí por supuesto víctor
que hemos bajado nosotros indudablemente
en la pobreza creo que son cuatro
millones de colombianos que que van que
están pasando de la línea de pobreza y
otros a otro otra proporción similar a
la línea de pobreza extrema aquí lo que
tenemos que insistir es en cómo son
generamos soluciones y no solamente como
seguimos incendiando el país qué es lo
que muchos sectores que generan odio es
lo que le apuesta representante gracias
y vuelvo con víctor de currea víctor qué
posibilidades reales existe en este
diálogo que llamó el gobierno para poder
salir de esta crisis además le quiero
preguntar qué tan fortalecida queda la
oposición con todo esto que está
ocurriendo en el país particularmente
gustavo petro que aspira a la
presidencia el año que viene en 2020
espero que me esté escuchando el lugar
todavía hay una propuesta que hemos
hecho desde las organizaciones sociales
para reactivar la economía se llama
renta básica
el profesor luego regala y ha demostrado
hay siete proyectos de ley sobre cómo
hacer renta básica la renta básica
permite salir de la crisis financiera y
ganan hasta los empresarios entonces me
parece que es una salida para el
gobierno ha entendido de la renta básica
o cree que renta básica son 70 mil pesos
mensuales segundo lo de las vacunas
también en eso estamos de acuerdo hay
que resolver el problema de vacunación
perdonen que diga mi profesión yo además
soy médico el problema de eso es que
hemos aprendido que eso no se hace sin
cercos epidemiológicos que
responsabilidad la cps y sin dignidad
del personal de salud entonces la ley
010 es lo que menos sirve estamos de
acuerdo como garantizamos no vacunar
sino resolver los problemas de salud del
país retiren el proyecto y 010 en eso
estamos de acuerdo y lo otro si
realmente quieren va a cobrar el país yo
invito a edward a que hable con su
partido y le pregunten al señor duque
porque ese pero porque colombia insiste
en negarse a apoyar la la suspensión de
patentes a nivel mundial colombia se ha
convertido en el paro en la rueda de la
organización mundial de comercio
el señor joe biden presidente de los
eeuu acaba de decir estoy de acuerdo con
liberar las patentes para que produzcan
vacunas del mundo y el señor duque en
siempre reuniones del organismo mental
del comercio no lo hace creo que tenemos
que plantear dos cosas la observancia
derechos humanos y la no-violencia sí
por supuesto tenemos que entonces
plantear caminos de diálogo ya no para
el 10 no para el 20 de mayo ya mismo
tenemos que discutir seriamente sobre la
economía del país en eso estamos de
corto con edward tenemos que garantizar
un modelo de salud adecuado pero además
necesitamos resolver el problema los
derechos humanos a mí me gustaría que el
centro democrático dijera vamos a hacer
una investigación seria para que tanto
los particulares como los miembros de la
fuerza pública que han participado en
crímenes durante estos días de protestas
sean juzgados el problema es que no
podemos presentar como héroes a uno y
como villanos a los otros yo aquí es
condenado por igual las violencias pero
el centro democrático parece que hay una
violencia buena y gran violencia mala y
ojalá seamos capaces dentro de este
paquete de reactivar el proceso de paz
sólo dos cositas se respetarán en la
constitución política de colombia y si
aplicáramos lo escrito el acuerdo de paz
de la habana créame eduard me alegra que
esté ahí créame que muchos de los
problemas se hubieran resuelto entonces
estamos de acuerdo que será sencillo el
problema fundamental es la política
social
pero que podemos conseguir en muchas
cosas y bueno y le vuelvo a insistir
leen algo que lo importante es
escucharnos y yo si no lo escucho vuelvo
a reiterar lo porque lo dije al
principio es condenables el que ataca la
fuerza pública que igualmente si la
fuerza pública ataca a un civil aún es
mayor responsabilidad que la fuerza
pública actúe del juego de derechos
humanos conforme a sus servidores
públicos para servir en lo público para
proteger a la ciudadanía pero no
obstante si vuelvo a insistir aquí hay
dos actos diferentes uno que son las
protestas que son sagradas que hay que
cuidarlas y otra la infiltración de
algunas organizaciones criminales y
extranjeras en esas protestas de tal
manera que si no no si no fue claro
condeno aún más cuando una fue cuando un
miembro de la fuerza pública actúa por
fuera de la ley y actúa solo examen
representante le quiero preguntar algo
que me llamó la atención como usted lo
dijo y también otros representantes del
partido de gobierno del centro demócrata
y es que muchos no están de acuerdo con
esta reforma tributaria que presentó en
su totalidad que presentó el presidente
y dando que hay divisiones dentro del
partido
pues mire parte de lo que el partido
hace es generar democracia interna yo
por ejemplo vengo de un municipio de de
boyacá
de aquitania boyacá yo soy víctima de la
violencia cuando tenía apenas seis años
mi hermano mayor fue asesinado nos
desplazamos para bogotá soy del colegio
público a través de un crédito en el
icex pude estudiar en la universidad
libre de colombia pero además de eso me
he formado y he podido capacitar me y
hoy en día tengo el mandato de 105 mil
ciudadanos que es la mayor votación en
la historia de colombia y he hecho unas
leyes muy importantes en contra de la
corrupción judicial hice al cartel de la
toga hice una serie de elementos y de
herramientas para combatir la corrupción
para proteger al medio ambiente y para
generar en legalidad en colombia en mi
partido hay extremos hay diferentes
visiones y eso tiene que ser respetado
yo daría mi vida
la otra persona de mi partido o de
cualquier otro partido pueda decir en
democracia lo que bien tenga a fin de
que podamos construir y es que vuelvo a
insistir en algo que el país y tiene que
reflexionar es escucharnos tenemos que
aprendernos a escuchar qué opina el uno
que opina el otro y de esa manera
también sacar conclusiones no como en
cuentos sino realmente entender que
entre todos podemos sumar yo estoy a
generando en el congreso en la república
una frase que nace de mi corazón y es
que esto tiene que ser como la pirinola
que era un jueguito que usábamos antes y
donde todos ponemos porque si todos
ponemos y todos contribuimos con ideas y
todos ayudamos a solucionar los
problemas absolutamente todos ganamos
escucharnos y actuar porque parece que
ya no hay tanto accionar del gobierno en
este caso el presidente iván duque
porque si no nos diéramos viendo todo
esta ola de indignación que estamos
viendo en todo el país ahora voy con
víctor de currea
víctor que viene para colombia
yo veo como varios escenarios la primera
es el riesgo de un golpe militar no es
tan posible pero yo no lo descarto es
decir no ha habido tradición de golpes
militares en colombia lo único que ha
habido lo colocaron las élites que fue
el de rojas pinilla pero digamos en un
porcentaje pequeño hay que tenerlo en el
en el en el análisis segundo un manejo
autoritario la posibilidad de que el
presidente duque llame decrete la
conmoción interior y veamos esas
represiones que vivimos o que vivieron
una muy joven durante el gobierno de
turbay ayala bajo el estatuto de
seguridad eso es otro escenario y lo
otro es que busquen una salida para
legitimarse a última hora que
perfectamente puede ser remover del
puesto a taiwán duque colocar a marta
lucía ramírez la vicepresidente como
presidenta y tratar de una manera más de
maquillaje o lo otro que es lo que ahora
se está pidiendo en el centro
democrático que es un diálogo nacional
en ese diálogo nacional tienen que estar
todas las fuerzas del país pero sobre
todo cumplirle a unos mandatos digamos
constitucionales del constituyente
primero
que es el que está ahí nosotros
esperamos de verdad que no haya más
muertes de ningún lado de verdad
esperamos que la policía deje de estar
infiltrando las marchas y sobre eso hay
demasiada evidencia esto no es una
narrativa cualquier periodista
internacional de los que ha estado
cubriendo las conoce y sabe que no es
mentira entonces queremos eso él
queremos que no hayan helicópteros del
ejército aterrizando en bosa y en suba
queremos que no se corte el internet en
cali para que no se pueda denunciar la
situación queremos que no hayan jóvenes
desaparecidos y muertos tenemos datos
fidedignos claros comprobados
creemos que no haya razones para que
naciones unidas la unión europea y eeuu
estén censurando la actitud del es del
gobierno colombiano entonces abran el
diálogo pero el diálogo no puede ser con
una agenda cerrada que no corresponde a
la realidad del país con unas
prioridades que como decía eduardo lo
prioritario es no no no lo prioritario
lo que el país considera prioritario
entonces edwards de verdad hay un sector
de la sociedad que está dispuesto a
salvar
pero no se trata de salvar el gobierno
de duke porque las instituciones no la
señora que mañana tiene que ir a
comprarle el arroz el señor que va a
comprar los huevos las instituciones no
le dicen nada es la realidad del país
pero yo espero a eduard además que como
tú te colocas con una persona de estrato
de origen humilde al igual que yo de
colegio público y defensor del medio
ambiente espero que tú seas un defensor
de la lucha contra el fracking y a favor
de los páramos dentro del centro
democrático y que seas un defensor como
lo has hecho aquí de el de la sociedad
en contra de los desmanes del es más
gracias víctor edward sus conclusiones
muy rápidamente para mí para volver
terminado el programa luego le voy a
mandar además para que porque veo que
usted es muy estudioso del tema todos
los proyectos de ley que además son
hermosos de protección ambiental y
coincido con usted en muchos temas
protección a los páramos acabamos de
hacer un proyecto de ley que permite
sembrar árboles en todas las ciudades es
una agenda ambiental ambiciosa que tengo
pero después lo voy a seguir en twitter
para qué
hablemos por ese medio pero miren
pongámonos de acuerdo y en estos días
hacíamos un análisis en otro programa
sobre algunos temas urgentes y un tema
que tiene que ser amplio como usted lo
dice los temas urgentes es la política
social como la vamos a solucionar cómo
vamos a ayudar a los ciudadanos más
pobres
ojalá coincidir en un tema que para mí
me parece que es espectacular porque es
de lo que yo he vivido que es la
educación gratuita que yo no tuve porque
gracias a dios a través de un crédito en
el visita ex puede estudiar pero que
tiene que dar oportunidades a todos los
colombianos es la única forma en mi
criterio de salir de la pobreza y tres
que creo que es fundamental es de dónde
vamos a sacar esos recursos cómo lo
vamos a hacer y yo sí creo y se lo digo
abiertamente y es lo que hemos hablado
con el presidente de duke en diferentes
partes del país con la ciudadanía es que
los que más tienen más que en verdad eso
hace parte de lo que estamos proponiendo
en el país
eduard muchísimas gracias por aceptar
nuestra invitación para dialogar acá en
france 24 y analizar
lo que está ocurriendo en colombia
panorama complejo y delicado político y
social por supuesto a usted también
víctor de correa por atendernos la
invitación y estar en este debate para
buscar pues también soluciones a todo
esto que estamos viendo en colombia en
la ciudad de bogotá en la ciudad de cali
por supuesto a nuestros periodistas a
marina sardiña que estaba cubriendo
todas las movilizaciones en la capital
colombiana y ayudes muñoz desde la
ciudad de cali también epicentro de
actos de violencia de la protesta
pacífica de la protesta también indígena
a todos ustedes gracias siempre también
por estar siempre ahí sintonizando con
nuestro canal y los invito a que se
quede con nosotros para más
actualización de noticia nos vemos en
unos minutos
[Música]